du vandalisme ignoble réaction de la
chancelière allemande angela merkel deux
jours après des scènes d'émeutes et de
pillages à stuttgart
une dizaine de policiers ont été blessés
des vitrines ont été brisées des
devantures de magasins pillés cela s'est
passé dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
des violences urbaines qui ont éclaté à
la suite d'un contrôle de police pour
une affaire de stupéfiants
le récit de françois xavier lambert la
succession de vitrines brisées
témoignaient de la violence des
émeutiers
sur cette grande artère commerçante de
stuttgart
neuf magasins ont été pillés 14 autres
endommagées le résultat d'un contrôle de
police qui a dégénéré dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche
bilan de ces affrontements une vingtaine
d'interpellations et plus d'une dizaine
de policiers blessés
des scènes de vandalisme qui concerne
les habitants j'ai découvert la boutique
vers 6 heures du matin avec mes
collègues de toute la ville a été
confronté à de nombreux problèmes à
cette violence nous sommes tous touchés
qui était ce pour quoi ils sont arrivés
je ne sais pas bien sûr il est difficile
que la police soit présente partout seul
aurait pu être pire s'ils avaient été
appelés ailleurs je veux dire que
stuttgart n'est pas habitué à ça
peut-être qu'à prendre force est
différent mais ici non j'ai été surpris
des incidents similaires s'étaient déjà
produits les week-ends précédents dans
la ville mais cette fois la police
décrit des affrontements d'une violence
inédite
je peux vous dire qu'il n'ya jamais eu
de telles scènes à stuttgart auparavant
surtout que cela vient de l'expérience
décrit par les collègues des violences
perpétrées contre eux simplement parce
qu'ils étaient policiers et parce qu'ils
sont intervenus la police exclut pour
l'instant toute motivation politique et
privilégient l'hypothèse d'un individu
alcoolisé
parmi les émeutiers interpellés le chef
de la police site des ressortissants
croates ce portugais mais aussi
somaliens ou encore afghans